الى العراق حيث كشفت مصادر رسميه لرايترز
ان الحكومه العراقيه وحكومه اقليم كردستان
توصلت الى اتفاق نهائي لاستئناف تصدير
النفط من الشمال ومن المقرر ان يعلن عنه
اليوم الثلاثاء وقال مسؤول في الحكومه في
بغداد انه جرى ارسال طلب رسمي الى تركيا
لاستئناف تصدير النفط عبر خط انابيب جهانه
تركي على ان يجري استئناف الضخ لساعات
القليله المقبله بحسب
من اربيل ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه احمد
الحمداني احمد مرحبا بك لعلي يبدا معك
اولا بزياره التي ينوي القيام بها او
الزياره التي ينوي بها القيام رئيس
العراقي في في الى بغداد حول موضوع
الاتفاق الى اي مدى انتهت كل الاجراءات
لتوقيع هذا الاتفاق الان في بغداد
بالفعل خالد توجه من اربيل قبل اكثر من
ساعه رئيس وزراء اقليم كردستان حكومه
تقليم كردستاني مسرور بارزاني وصل الى
بغداد وصل الى العاصمه العراقيه بغداد كان
باستقبالها الملفت هذه المره انه كان في
استقباله وزير النفط الاتحادي على راس وفد
وزاري عبد الغني وطبعا سرعه انا ما طبعا
وهذه رساله كبيره لكل المراقبين ان وزير
النفط المجيئه التي لديها خلاف منذ عقد من
الزمان مع اقليم كردستان هو بنفسه من
يستقبل على راسي وفد الوزاريه استقبل رئيس
وزراء وحكومه اقليم كردستان التي ربما
ستوقع او ستنهي تنهي ملف الخلافات وستنضم
الى سومو عبر سومو سيكون التصدير النفط
النفط كردستان عبر الشركه العراقيه
الموجوده ببغداد والتي تصدر نفط مسؤول عن
تنظيم
صادرات النفط العراقيه السومو بعد ان يكون
طبعا شروط وهي ان يكون نائب رئيس الشركه
العراقيه سومو كردي وان يكون هناك مشاركه
كرديه في قرارات سومو وبالتالي طبعا لبى
بغداد لبت كل شروط وكل التفاهمات صارت
ببغداد على ان يكون اعضاء سومو من كردستان
وايضا بالمقابل يكون ايرادات نفط كردستان
الى صندوق خاص او حساب خاص تشرف عليه
بغداد وايضا سومه بالتالي فان ننتظر ننتظر
كل تحبس الانفاس حتى يكون هناك توقيع رسمي
ما بين محمد شياع السوداني رئيس وزراء
الاتحاد وبين رئيس وزراء اقليم كردستان
الذين الان بحسب مصادرهم يجتمعون وقد
استقبل الشيعه السوداني بارزاني قبل قليل
في مكتبه وهم في اجتماع ونتوقع ان يكون
هناك مفاجات بتوقيع او
فتح او انضمام رسميا النفط اقليم كردستان
الى موازنه او ايرادات بغداد او الى حل
المشاكل جزئيا في هذه المرحله التي ستكون
هناك مراحل كثيره في مشاكل